we're good to go my name is Reuben Kumar
and I want to welcome Ben Cohen he's
gonna be doing time interrupted
measuring intervention effects with
interrupted time series analysis I just
want to write everyone shut your
cellphone's off trying turning the
volume down on your laptop so we don't
have any interruptions
all the Thaksin tutorials will be
recorded so they'll be online pi data
records all of them so you can watch the
other recorded PI data talks from New
York or Cordoba as well online if you
enjoy this format and can you all give
me a i'll help me give a warm welcome to
you Ben Cohen hi everyone and welcome
sorry sorry for the AV difficulties but
you know first talk of the day so there
you go so this talk is time interrupted
measuring intervention effects with
interrupted time series analysis a
little bit about myself my name is Ben
Cohen and I'm a data scientist at Warby
Parker I'm sorry the clicker there we go
sorry I'm a data scientist Warby Parker
and for those of you who aren't familiar
may not be familiar with Warby Parker
this is a bit of our mission statement
from our website but you know
essentially we're we're a company that
sells eyeglasses and sunglasses and we
were founded about eight years ago and
we started out as an e-commerce company
but we've now expanded a lot and we also
now have around 80 retail stores in the
United States and two in Canada and a
big part of our business model is that
you know we do a lot of things in-house
everything from designing our glasses to
you know running our own customer
service and that extends to our tech
infrastructure as well so you know while
we do use some off-the-shelf software
we've also written internal software for
a lot of things in our business
everything from supply chain management
to order processing
our retail point of sale and what this
means is that we have a lot of data so
this data science team at Warby Parker
really supports stakeholders throughout
the company by helping them make better
decisions with data and like I said we
have a lot of different kinds of data
that we work with but this talk is about
some work that we did with the marketing
team so what is interrupted time series
analysis it's a form of causal inference
and it's designed for situations where
traditional experiments are impossible
and I'll give some examples of the
situations in a bit but first I want to
go over what I mean when I say
traditional experiments so this comes up
a lot in in in digital performance
marketing so this is an area where we
often apply experimental design and you
know we have a lot of tools are built
around digital marketing to help us and
and basically you know the way that they
work is they've give us the ability the
revolutionary ability relate to do
direct attribution in advertising right
so when you look at an ad online we know
you know who sees it who clicks on it
what they do later on our website
whether they become a customer etc and
and you know a lot of a lot of our
industry is built around this and you
know one of the core tools that we use
here is a B testing and this is
something that's enabled by this direct
attribution so let's talk about a/b
testing I'm sure that a lot of people
here are familiar with it but I'm just
going to give a brief overview you know
the idea is that we have some population
of customers or of individuals and we
randomly bucket them into two into two
or more groups or you know and those
versions those groups you know could be
called treatment and control and we show
them different versions of something so
different versions of our website or of
an advertisements and then for each of
those groups we measure target metrics
like conversion rate or
you know clicks on the website etc and
then by compare the metrics for those
two groups and we can use a statistical
model to make some inference about the
effect of the differences between what
we showed them and so this could be a
traditional you know kind of null
hypothesis the significance test or you
know a Bayesian model there's lots of
different approaches to a/b testing but
that's the the basic idea
so now the problem that happened
recently is that you know our our we we
wanted to do a national TV campaign and
we haven't done this a lot and our
marketing team came came to us ask for
help in figuring out how to measure the
impact of this so you know we're showing
national TV ads do we make money from
this and so there's a big problem with
this which is that with TV there's no
way to randomize exposures and beyond
that there's actually even no way to
even know who saw the ad so a lot of
times you may have a Gregorian TV
program but when you're when you're
talking about an individual person
coming to your website there's no way of
knowing whether or not they were exposed
to a TV commercial so you know one one
thing that you could do to sort of
replicate the idea behind a be test is
geo-targeting right so you could run the
ad in certain cities or certain markets
that are similar to each other and and
compare across geographies and that way
you you could sort of capture some of
the idea behind an a/b test although it
wouldn't be strictly randomized but this
has one big drawback which is that it's
really expensive it turns out that it's
way more expensive you know on a per
impression basis to do locally targeted
TV ads and to do national ones and in
our case we really wanted to run ads
nationally in order to get that higher
larger reach so we needed a different
approach so I want to take a step back
and ask a fundamental question how can
we know if something we did had an
effect so the big problem is that there
are a lot of different causal factors
that can impact how many people go to a
website or buy a product right so you
know
it could be that the added we showed
them was the causal factor but it could
be something about you know who they are
their demographics it could be you know
other ads that they saw or you know all
kinds of different things the time of
day and so you want to control for the
ones that you care about in this case
exposure to the TV ad and and control
and control for all the other ones that
you that you don't care about and so you
know in science we have a gold standard
for this it's randomized controlled
trials and this is you know the classic
experimental design behind for example
clinical drug trials right the idea is
that you randomly assign from your
target population into treatment and
control groups and the idea behind this
is that the randomization controls for
your confounding factors because you if
you if you start with the same group of
people and you randomize them then you
can be pretty sure that the only
difference between the groups is your
treatment and if this sounds familiar
it's because a beeper set a be testing
is precisely randomized controlled trial
but typically in a digital medium and
again the problem here is that with our
TV example is that we can't have a
control group because we don't actually
control the assignment process and and
we don't know who's in what group we
aren't able to observe people who
weren't exposed to the intervention
right we know you know we know that some
people saw the intervention and some
some people saw the ad and some people
didn't but we don't know which ones are
which right and so stating the problem
this way can lead to a useful
reformulation of the problem a
restatement of the problem which is what
would have happened if we hadn't shown
the ad to anybody so again we know that
out of the population some fraction of
people saw the ad but we don't know who
that is
but we can't ask the question what have
we just hadn't done this at all and
hadn't shown the ad to anybody and this
is an example of a counterfactual you
know and I put the definition up here
but basically a counterfactual is a
snare
oh that didn't happen right and the idea
here is that if we can guess the
counterfactual we can estimate the
effect by comparing it with what
actually did happen and so this this
problem of guessing the counterfactual
you know transforms the problem into a
prediction problem predicting the
counterfactual and fortunately for us as
data scientists prediction is something
that we that you know that's our bread
and butter so this brings us to
interrupt a time series so there are
many ways of constructing counterfactual
models and and there you know there's a
whole field of causal inference that
deals with this but I'm going to discuss
one particular technique and it relies
on two important properties that this
scenario has and also lots of other
similar scenarios so this this model i
TS is a counterfactual model that model
that works when first of all the
intervention begins at a specific known
point in time so we know exactly what
day and what time we started showing TV
ads right and we control that and then
also we have sequential observations
from both before and during the
intervention in other words we have you
know time series data about whatever
metrics we care about going back into
the past from before we were showing TV
ads and we also will continue collecting
them sequentially afterwards so to
capture the idea here take a look at
this plot from a hypothetical campaign
so what we have here is a time series
this could be you know sales or some
other metric that you care about and the
dashed line indicates where in time the
campaign starts and so just looking at
this plot I'm sure everyone here would
intuitively conclude that you know that
this campaign had a positive effect and
what's going on here is that based on
our understanding of the world and our
our beliefs we have a strong prior that
the data generating process would have
continued in a similar way absent the
intervention so essentially what you're
probably doing mentally is is fill
in the counterfactual like this and it's
precisely this intuition that the
technique of I TS seeks to formalize
this goes by various names sometimes the
counterfactual is referred to as a
baseline prediction I like the term
interrupted time series because it
highlights that what we're looking for
is a discontinuity in the in the time
series and in fact IITs could be
considered a special case of another
causal inference technique or our suite
of techniques called
regression discontinuity and it's a
special case because here the
discontinuity happens in time and this
technique is frequently used in
econometrics and social science and it
has a lot of other potential
applications particularly you know in
public health right so if you do some
sort of population level policy change
or an education other public policy
another potential application is an
outage postmortem you know so like let's
say your website goes down and you want
to you know you want to assess what the
impact was on your business but you you
actually don't have any data for when
that happens another one is when you
have to make a website changes but you
can't a be test right so sometimes there
may be depending on your industry there
may be a regulatory reason or some other
you know high corporate policy reason
why you have to make some change to your
to your website or you know to some
products and you're not allowed to a/b
test it right
another potential application is you
know if if you have some press piece
about your company or you know some PR
event you know something out of the
ordinary and you want to measure the
impact so I'm gonna go on and continue
using this TV campaign as a motivating
example but I just wanted to highlight
that it's a very general technique it
has a lot of potential applications so
how do you go about building a time
series counterfactual so let's look
again at this simple example and when I
say it's simple I deliberately made it
as as simple as I could so our data here
is just drawn from a normal distribution
so it's just white noise with a mean
that changes once a chain
the mean jumps up when the intervention
happens and so our counterfactual in
this case is just that the mean would
have stayed the same so in a case like
this all you have to do is look at the
summary statistics look at a histogram
of the data from before-and-after right
and you just have two normal
distributions and so you can you know
use your standard toolbox of statistical
tests and models to calculate the lifts
but of course in the real world we know
that our data will seldom or never look
like this and in particular it will tend
to differ in two key respects which I'll
discuss in turn so the first one is non
stationarity and so in the previous
example both the mean and the variance
of our time series stay the same over
time but that's not necessarily going to
be the case so in this example the mean
is changing over time and what we have
is that the the sales were actually
already trending up even before the
intervention and what this means is that
if we just naively summarize the data
from before and after like we did before
we're gonna get a nonsensical and
misleading results and in particular you
know if you just naively
you know average out the values here
you'll see that you know the the
variances of these two distributions
look totally different but that's that's
not really capturing what's really going
on so even if you just fix the mean at
its most recent value you know you're
still going to overestimate the lift
significantly here because again you're
not capturing the fact that that upward
trend and in fact you know if you think
about this as a business problem
overestimating the effect of your ad
spend is actually the worst case
scenario because it means that you're
going to be losing money and you won't
know it right you'll be wasting money on
ads that don't work so what you really
want is a model that understands how the
distribution is changing over time and
how we can extrapolate that into the
future right and so this is where time
series models come into play and the
other big problem is
other than non-stationarity as
auto-correlation right so you can have a
mean that roughly stays the same over
time but the values actually sort of
meander around the mean and what's going
on is that you know when you have
autocorrelation then the value at any
particular time step is correlated with
the value at a previous time step so
it's more likely that you'll see small
changes locally as opposed to large
changes and you know you can diagnose
this with it with an autocorrelation
plot and you know by the way if you had
a chance to go to the there was an
excellent time series models tutorial
yesterday where we you know went over
some of these things but anyway the
unfortunately these two properties knock
out many statists and 'red statistical
models and tests and regression models
because a lot of these techniques like
that we're used to using for a/b testing
make an assumption and IID assumption
about the data that it's independent and
identically distributed and
unfortunately what happens here is that
autocorrelation violates the
independence assumption and and non
stationarity violates the identically
distributed constraint so this is why we
need a dedicated time series model
through this kind of prediction and you
may have heard of some of these
different types of models there's a lot
of them out there you know exponential
smoothing ARIMA etc there's a there are
you know if you look online at like how
many different time series forecasting
packages there are there are literally
hundreds maybe thousands of them so I'm
not going to go into all of them but I
do want to talk about you know what they
sort of have in common which is that
fundamentally what they all try to do is
to make predictions by explicitly
modeling temporal structure in the data
so this time dependence in the data you
know you can think of it in one sense as
a nuisance because it means that you
have to throw a lot of standard the
standard toolbox out the window but
another way of thinking about it is that
it's actually really useful because this
temporal structure this time dependence
carries a lot of information about the
underlying process and therefore
predictive power
and this is what time series models try
to take advantage of so like I said I'm
not going to talk about all the
different ways that you could do time
series modeling you could really use any
of them for this technique but I want to
talk about the types of features that
can exist in in real world data and the
types of things that your models might
have to account for and in doing so I'll
explain sort of how we decided on what
tool to use so starting off simply again
you know you can have random noise that
may or may not have autocorrelation you
can have trend and it may be nonlinear
right so the the slope of the trend can
change at different points in time
you can have day of the week seasonality
this is very common for business data
right like people shop on certain days
of the week or you know people do
different things at different times and
then on top of that you can have you
know a lower frequency periodic effect
you know of annual seasonality where
things happen at different times of the
year and you can have holiday effects
where specific days of the year tend to
be outliers because of something that
you know that happens on that day I
think in this example I used national
donut day and national bagel day as the
holidays in this simulated data and the
last thing another thing is that you
know you can have other covariates
that that have some sort of causal
effect on on the data so in this example
there's another time series which is
your spend across other marketing
channels right so you know somebody
might have seen some of your online ads
and that could affect you know how they
how they behave you know in addition to
how they know whether or not they saw a
TV ad so another thing that you really
want from from a model especially in
this context is prediction intervals
it's very important in this particular
application to have a way of quantifying
uncertainty because again you know the
purpose if you think about the purpose
of doing this kind of modeling this kind
of attribution or lift modeling is that
it's really in some sense risk
mitigation you want to make sure that
your spend it has is has a positive
return on investments and you want to
have a sense of how confidence you are
about that and so if you only have a
point estimate it's very difficult to
know how much to trust that for example
if our model says that our ad generated
a 5% lift it's really different from a
business perspective if that confidence
interval is between 2 and 7% or if it's
between negative 5 and positive 15%
right that matters a lot in terms of how
you decide how to allocate resources as
a business so for this type of problem
having reliable prediction intervals can
be just as important if not more
important than the than just the
accuracy of the prediction itself but
there's actually a big problem with
generating prediction intervals or on
you know uncertainty bars in time series
forecasts and it's it's summed up in
this quote by Hindman from from his
textbook on time series forecasting but
basically what it says is that you know
typical typically time series models
have very poor empirical coverage of
their prediction intervals and there are
a number of reasons with that I'll get
to some of those later but one in large
part this this happens for a technical
reason which is that a lot of
traditional models like a Rhema will
incorporate you know a random error term
into the model but they they won't
necessarily incorporate uncertainty in
the parameter estimates and actually for
all but the simplest time series models
there's no closed-form or analytical way
of incorporating that kind of
uncertainty and so there are really two
primary options that people use one is
bootstrapping where essentially your
your resampling from your training data
and this actually is a little bit
perilous for time series data because of
that autocorrelation and on stationarity
right like how do you resample from a
time series it's actually pretty
complicated and then the other one is
Bayesian inference where you're actually
fitting instead
point estimates you're fitting a
posterior distribution for your
parameters so ultimately we decided to
go with a library called profit it's a
Facebook released open-source project
and it is a Bayesian it uses a Bayesian
inference engine under the hood and one
thing that's really cool about it is
that it it uses Stan which is a Bayesian
inference tool on the back end but it
has api's in both R and Python that are
you know basically 100% feature can
paddle
equivalents etc and it's built with
daily and sub daily business data in
mind it supports all these things I
mentioned before like changing trend
multiple different levels of seasonality
external regressors all that stuff so
you know I'm I'm not being paid by
Facebook to pitch this we we we found it
very useful but you know your mileage
may vary but we found that it that it
that was a good fit for this for this
problem so now I'm going to talk about
how you actually go about training and
prediction for interrupted time series
model so let's go back to our simulated
data set that I was showing you before
so this is the same artificial data set
but I've added a simulated campaign
period where I added about a 10% lift
after the dashed line and you know this
actually illustrates that because of the
complexity of the data here it's very
hard to eyeball this and and actually
know so that's you know why we need a
model so recall that our counterfactual
is that if we hadn't done anything that
the data generating process would have
continued in essentially the same way so
what that means is that what we do what
we're going to do is use the historical
data up until the beginning of the
campaign as our training data and then
we're going to make a prediction for
each time step during the campaign but
of course as good data scientists we
also need to be able to
test our data test our model rather and
we want to do that on out-of-sample
testing data so this is another tricky
thing to do but we went with a simple
approach where you know we cut the data
off a little ways before where our
predictions will start and then use that
as our test set so we're going to train
a model using all the data up to that
point and then a you know measure the
accuracy so now you can check you know
the accuracy of its predictions on the
test set and measure you know your
accuracy metrics so just a word of
warning here you want to be careful
about choosing accuracy metrics for a
time series model because some
traditional regression accuracy metrics
like root mean squared error can have
some problems where they're not scale
invariant if the variance changes over
time right so you just want to be
careful about that
so one popular choice is mean absolute
percentage error but there's other ones
including information criteria and
various other ways of measuring that you
know how good your model is you also
want to you know look at autocorrelation
in the residuals or the errors of your
model because if your errors are
correlated in time it basically means
that you're leaving predictive power on
the table you're not accounting for all
of the temporal structure time dependent
structure of the data and then lastly
you also really want to look at the
empirical coverage of your prediction
intervals so basically if your
confidence interval says you know if you
have a 95% confidence interval you want
to check that it actually contains the
true value roughly 95% of the time and
again that's because of this you know
this problem with coverage of prediction
intervals and so you know you kind of
just want to calibrate your uncertainty
metric so that you can trust it so once
you've done this and you're satisfied
with your model and your hyper
parameters etc you then can retrain the
model using all of the data up to the
beginning of the intervention and make
your forecast so here you can see that
the the blue line is the counterfactual
prediction and the green line as the
actual observed
and it may be hard to see in this view
but you know it looks like the the blue
line is slightly below the green line
meaning our model thinks that there was
some positive effect from the campaign
so let's talk about how we can actually
analyze that lift and try to quantify it
so one really nice thing about using a
Bayesian framework like profit is that
it gives you samples from the posterior
predictive distribution and the best way
to think about this is that it's
basically a probability distribution
over possible futures possible outcomes
and the nice thing about these samples
is that they're really easy to work with
to generate all kinds of summary
statistics and you can work with them to
empirically so for example this is how
we get prediction intervals you can
generate prediction intervals by looking
at the quantiles of your posterior
samples and here we generate that we can
generate them for both point wise so day
by day and cumulative metrics and this
is really useful because as you can see
in this case on any given day it looks
like there's a you know a small positive
effects but it actually may not be
outside of your margin of error but you
actually get more power when you look
cumulatively and that's because you know
intuitively a small lift on any
particular day could easily be a fluke
but if you see that same small lift
every day over a long period of time it
becomes less and less likely that it's a
coincidence and so what you can see in
the cumulative view on the right is that
pretty quickly as you look at cumulative
ly the the two lines the counterfactual
diverges from the actual observed values
and they move outside of the margin of
error
and another thing you can do is actually
get intervals around the lift itself and
you can do this just by subtracting the
the posterior samples from the actuals
and so in these views I'm showing lift
as a percentage and and here you can see
even more clearly how the cumulative
uncertainty actually tends to shrink
over time and you can see that for many
individual days we're not you know 95%
sure that the
a positive effect at all but that the
the margin of error is quite a bit
smaller when you look cumulatively but
it's still useful to look at multiple
different time scales because you know
in real life your TV campaign your
intervention may not have this simple
you know step change effect that that
the example has right so you can have
some combination of a change in level or
a change in slope there can be a delayed
effect or there can be you know decay
etc and so if you want to get some
insights into this it can be useful to
look at multiple different time scales
and you know lastly you know another
useful feature of using a Bayesian
package like like profit is is that it
makes it really easy to answer
probability based questions like what's
the probability that the cumulative lift
was greater than or equal to five
percent or some other cutoff point
that's meaningful to the business and
this is a really useful way of
communicating results to stakeholders so
in the last section of the talk I'm
going to talk about some threats to
validity so you know I've gone through
interrupted time series analysis and
maybe painted a little bit of a rosy
picture of it and in the truth is that
it's a very useful technique but as
always there are caveats so you know in
the literature this is often referred to
as a quasi experimental design and
that's really you know just to emphasize
that it's not as good as a real
experiment you know your counterfactual
is not the same as having a control
group because it's something that you
didn't actually observe it's something
you're making an inference about and so
you can only have some sort of
probabilistic idea about it and
therefore you can't make nearly as
strong of a causal claim as you could
with a randomized experiment so so
excuse me
so the first threat the ability I want
to talk about is that there's there's
some change in the underlying process so
you know basically the the the
underlying data generating process
change during the during the forecast
period you know it's some fundamental
way so this model assumes that any lifts
you see during the campaign period is a
is attributable to your intervention but
that might not be a valid assumption you
know something could change globally you
know the economy could tank or a
competitor could release a product you
know some unobserved thing could happen
that changes the the fundamental
dynamics of the process of the system
and so there are two ways I want to talk
about that you can sort of mitigate this
so one is that you can look both before
and after the intervention period so if
you have a scheduled end to your
intervention then you know under this
counterfactual assumption you would
expect that things would kind of go back
to the way that they were before and so
if that doesn't happen that's that's a
warning sign that something changed
something else changed that you weren't
accounting for and and secondly you can
look at other similar time series that
you know you think follow a similar
process but should be unaffected by your
intervention so for example if you have
access to market level data for your
industry you know then you would expect
that like the same underlying you know
global factors would affect that but if
your model is predicting that you know
your ad boosted your competitors sales
then that's probably a sign that
something else is is going wrong like it
that something else is going on that
your model doesn't know about sometimes
these kinds of changes can be modeled
explicitly as confounding variables so
in this case the problem could simply be
that there are causal factors known
causal factors that your model doesn't
account for so for example you know
somebody could you know so somebody else
in the biz
could have you know increased the spend
on some other marketing channel and they
didn't tell you about it or something
like that or you know there was well you
know there was bad weather and so you
know nobody came into your store and
oftentimes and so in both of those cases
you know there's now an identification
problem in your model but if you if you
can think of those factors and you have
data on them then you can add them as
covariates into your model so in the
example I gave earlier you know we
include our spend across different
channels in the model and therefore you
know we can we can control for that
lastly you know even if there isn't some
causal factor you're not accounting for
obviously your model could still be
misspecified you know it failed to
capture reality so you know there could
be problems with your the convergence of
your model
it could be overly confident it could be
overfitting etc all of the typical types
of issues that we deal with in every
kind of modeling you know all models are
misspecified
to some degree so you can ever escape
this but there are certain things you
can do to build trust so one is that you
can compare several models so one
practical example of this is you know in
doing a TV campaign we work with an
outside agency partner and they have
their own team of data scientists that
that built their own in-house
attribution model and we can compare the
answers from the two models that were
developed independently and and get a
sense of you know whether they agree or
disagree and that can you know give us
some insight into how much to trust
either one and then another a similar
approach is to assess multiple outcome
variables so you know you can look at
sales or you can look at click-through
rate or you can look at you know unique
visitors you could look in retail or
online right these are all different
outcomes that are correlated with each
other but not perfectly correlated so
hopefully by by modeling all of them
separately you know you could see if one
of them had a spurious results you know
or whether they all agree with each
other
so I'm going to conclude with some folk
wisdom it's difficult to make
predictions especially about the future
you know it's not a silver bullet and
it's just one of many ways that you can
you know look at marketing data or any
other kind of data to try to assess the
performance of your marketing or
whatever you're doing and if you have
the choice it's always best to do a
controlled experiment that's always
going to give you the most reliable
causal inference but there are many
cases in the real world where that's not
possible and in those cases using a
counterfactual method like interrupted
time series analysis can oftentimes be
the next best thing so thank you very
much
and I will take questions
[Applause]
thank you hi I was wondering whether you
could speak more to the business
application of this at Warby Parker and
in particular how what kind of metrics
you look that look at for the time
series and how you define the after
intervention period since I imagine
people buy glasses relatively
infrequently and may not interact much
with Warby Parker otherwise yeah that's
a good question so yeah we look at we
look at a bunch of different ones like I
said so you know that obviously and and
that's a good point that different
metrics can have different time lags so
the first match the first metric that
we'll see you know the the place where
we'll see the effect is soonest is if
somebody comes to our website right that
will happen pretty shortly after you
know after you see the ad although
sometimes you hope you may have to see
the ad several times or you may think of
it later right in terms of our business
you know one of the one of the really
cool unique things about our company is
our home Tryon program and that's a
program we have where you can try on
five free pairs at home with free
shipping and return shipping etc and you
can you know pick which one you like and
so we look at the number of people who
sign up for a home Tryon and then you
know we have lots of historical data
about you know what you know how long it
takes for people to convert from a home
Tryon etc and then we also like I said
we have now a large chain of retail
stores as well and so we can look at
metrics from those to see if you know if
a campaign is impacting whether people
go into the stores or not
other questions
can you share an example of a situation
where this worked well like you had a
high confidence in your counterfactual
and we're there any situations where you
tried this where you just couldn't find
a good counterfactual prediction yeah so
I think that well you know one one I
don't know if I can give a specific
example but one one type of thing that
could happen that that could be
confusing right is that if you're if
your actual metrics are below where you
predicted the counterfactual that can be
confusing right because there there's
not a plausible causal mechanism that
says that like doing more advertising
will cause people to shop less so that
is a pretty good indication that there's
something you're missing you know that
there was something wrong with your with
your prediction I mean in terms of when
it works well I think that again like
when you have agreement between the
different KPIs or between different
independent models that were made using
slightly different assumptions you know
the more you have agreement between
different methods I think the more trust
you have in it I have a question about
comparing different like channels of
advertisement and then figure out like
which one was more effective do you do
any of that like basically compare the
value of different channels not for TV
advertisement versus digital or
something like that yeah
so that's that's a you know that's what
that's an interesting question so so you
know one of the things that we're trying
to do here again is like model the other
channels and then you know this is a
pretty unique situation in that we
recently started doing TV ads right so
you have this like clear demarcation in
time of when something starts and stops
as far as measure comparing other
channels yeah I mean I think that that's
like a whole other other topic but you
know there's all kinds of you know
regression based approaches that you can
use for that one one one reason that
that can be tricky to do actually is
that
you can often have a lot of
multicollinearity between different
channels so there's a lot there you know
that's it's a fraught topic and there's
a lot of issues with I did a
identification there he talked a little
bit about the data preparation for being
able to view an interrupted time series
you kind of have this clean segment of
data leading up to your intervention but
I can imagine there are times where
there are different ad campaigns running
in sequence and sometimes right after
the other that might influence your your
after effect and also will affect your
attempt to do this on the next campaign
yeah totally I think I said this is
pretty new to us as a company so we
haven't had to deal with too many of
that kind of that kind of situation but
I mean I think that you know ultimately
there's no free lunch right like if like
being intentional about how you design
an X you know this is still even though
it's not a you know a randomized
experiment it's still an experiment in
some in the sense that we're deciding to
start doing ads at a certain time you
know and so I think having some
intentionality and and communicating
across the business about how you plan
to how you plan to to launch these
things how you plan to measure them I
think that's really key to getting a
good outcome so my name is Ravi and I
have a question regarding the ramp up
period so when you in one of your slide
you said there is a like when the
intervention starts so you was laying
down a time series and they're in
dimension starts and then you have a
different time series but in most
businesses there is a ramp up period
because the website is not rolled out to
all users or things like that the
product is not rolled out to all the
stores so how do you analytically
determine what should be the correct
ramp up period before you start
measuring the effect yes so I mean
that's a good question I think you know
if you have a slow ramp up period then
this then this may not be the best
design because again like if you have
the option to compare subgroups some of
whom you know we're exposed and some
weren't then you can use other types of
experimental or quasi-experimental
designs so interrupted time series is
really targeted at situations
you don't have the ability to control
the rollout in that way
hi my name is sort of a you mentioned
about the cases week where we can't do a
B testing right and if you do a
counterfactual
so how do we actually access the our
counterfactual is you know correct or
how do you forecast with our
counterfactual compared to the original
time series that has happened after the
intervention or in effect yes so I think
that's why it's really you know again
it's it's vulnerable to the to the the
threat to the validity that that you
know you have to make a pretty strong
assumption that the underlying dynamics
of the system of the business etcetera
are going to be relatively stable during
the window that you're interested in
right and and so then what you know
given that assumption you know you can
use your traditional a typical suite of
of model checking tools so it is really
important to test these models on some
kind of out-of-sample you know holdout
set and so like I said there's a whole
you know the same tool box you can use
in general for assessing how much to
trust a model I think is applicable here
but again it is it is vulnerable in that
you have to you have to make that
assumption about about the underlying
process staying the same all right thank
you everyone if there are more questions
you know find me afterwards that I'm
happy to talk to people in person thank
you